This is a hot take that you guys may or may not hate me for,
but I got an email last night from one of you.
It was a 22 year old girl asking me about female hustle culture
and like, saying that she,
at 22, feels a really heavy emotional weight
put on her by her female family members
that are quote
unquote brainwashed by female hustle culture.
Um, because she doesn't wanna go to college,
doesn't want a career, and just wants to live the slow feminine life.
Let me just say this. Like,
if you do not have a husband that can provide for you comfortably,
if you do, if you are not a full time mother
with a husband that can provide for your family,
if you do not have a family that can provide comfortably for you, too,
live slow, right?
Like, you need to have a job.
You need to work. Like,
you have to provide value.
And don't get it twisted. Yes,
I work from home. Yes,
my boyfriend helps me with,
oh, like,
the roof over my head and with stocking our freezer full of meat.
But I still have bills to pay.
I still work full time. I work for his company,
I run my own business. I managed three social media accounts.
Like, I constantly work and provide value.
I have hobbies, I have passions,
I'm constantly learning, I'm constantly elevating myself.
Trying to heal more,
trying to figure out More ways to add value to the world.
My man and I work as a unit.
We work as a team. Of course,
we have polarity,
and our relationship is the masculine and the feminine,
because I believe that that's absolutely.
We both do believe it's absolutely necessary
for the health of your relationship
to have that polarity. However,
we also know that if we put together our minds in our unique skill set,
that we can cultivate financial freedom
and that slower lifestyle so much faster.
My boyfriend has a spinal injury that gives him constant,
chronic pain every single day of his life.
And he is still busting his absolute ass
to scale his pickleball company.
And I help him with that because I have a unique skill set.
I run my own business, and, like,
it's a very fun. It's.
It's a grind. It's for sure a grind.
But we know that it will be so worth it
and that two minds are greater than one.
And diminishing myself as a woman,
to say that my only value is,
like, my womb is so wrong.